so you've dedicated your life to UK
you've traveled around the country
trying to win elections for them and
this weekend the party's only MP has
quit
thank God you must be gutted are you
thank God that look he's been working
against us for a very long time sadly
too many in UK were prepared to give him
the benefit of the doubt I wanted to
kick him out back in 2015 for being
disloyal for working against this but
the good thing is we've got a new leader
and the last thing he wants is somebody
causing division every time as a
conference we had problems with Carswell
and I think the poor Nuttall this is
very good news the same time there
You've tries to be elected seven times
and you've lost your eye to five times
he'd be trying to take notes from
douglas Carswell he's actually he has
got he has got the most Eurostat
Euroskeptic constituency in the country
out of all 650 seats
klaxon is the seat where you can win
hello he joined us in 2014 we won that
by-election we want another by-election
and it was it was a great thing for the
party at the time and it didn't last
very long because he never ever believed
in the principles that you keep stood
for so do you think he's a conservative
infiltrator then
well that was how it turned out yes but
I mean look this is a guy who always
sells himself as being very honorable
and different to everybody else and one
of his big Crusades in Parliament has
been recalled real recall where he
himself has said if 20% of the
constituents wanna buy election they
should have won so what we're gonna do
will test how honorably is we're gonna
write through the petrol reform Society
to every house and Clacton and ask
people whether they want him as he's
moved to stand for a by-election and
perhaps then we'll find out who the real
douglas Carswell is so in that case then
what are you gonna put your money where
your mouth is would you stand in Clapton
order what about South fun it if they
rerun that well let's see let's see I
mean let's see what happens this is all
in the hands of the Crown Prosecution
Service I can't odds what's gonna happen
there but if if they do decide to rerun
that election would you stand probably
and I haven't really made my mind up
probably but look you know the really
big story of the week isn't douglas
Carswell
it's article 50 it's happening on
Wednesday and we will then have passed
the point of no return we are leaving
the European Union but the point about
you clip is what terms will leave the
European Union under I mean just today
am a Sunday Times
let's talk that may be sure
living in Warsaw will continue to
qualify for Child Benefit yes we're
leaving
but UKIP's role I think now is to make
sure we do it on the right terms that's
you're setting out the mission statement
of a UK after an article 50 young
Trickett but of course it's gonna be
quite difficult for your party isn't it
let's be honest i mean that's what
douglas Carswell is saying you Kipps won
the victory so what's the point in
sticking around this moon wonder really
be winning the wall as leadership it's
winning the war is very very important
but also you have to win the peace the
peace is far from one already I can see
where this government concessions being
made over fishing the desire of the
Prime Minister the same part of the
European Arrest Warrant you know this is
not over by a long shot
you've got no MPs now with no MP's we
forced a referendum in this country in
many ways outside Parliament you keeps
achievement has been astonishing I'm
keen to talk as well about the tragic
attack in London that happened this week
the Westminster terror attacks where
four people were killed including a
policeman trying to God permit now in
the aftermath of that attack you took to
the American airwaves before much
information had come out and I just want
to have a look at what what you did say
if you open your door to uncontrolled
immigration from Middle Eastern
countries you are inviting in terrorism
well that's right isn't it it's not
relevant to five of the eight five of
the eight people who committed that
barbarity in Paris had come in across
the military we're not talking about a
new drove the person who drives that
we're not talking about the barbarity I
know actually talking about the actually
as it turned out well the fact that it's
homegrown terrorism is even worse the
fact is this guy was radicalized inside
a prison you know Theresa May was Home
Secretary thing is I'd like to know why
people are being radicalized inside
schools and prisons surely that's
something we can prevent I absolutely
accept that that is a huge
radicalization but I do just want to go
back to the specifics because you were
talking about uncontrolled immigration
yes I'll just admit you got it wrong
you're wrong great talking my goodness
gracious me just have a look I was
talking about
attacks in Europe and I said and I said
and I said we did not know what the
cause of this attack was I was
absolutely clear and specific however
now that the deal with Turkey is clearly
breaking down very bad relations between
you know the Netherlands and Turkey we
Europe now faces you know perhaps an
even bigger migrant tide this summer
but it's had before and it has no way of
protecting itself against terrorists
coming and that is a very real issue and
actually I think it's one of the reasons
we've only four brexit you see again
you're talking about your views on
immigration which I respect I understand
your position on immigration but I'm
just what I'm trying to get a book to is
the link between that immigration and
what happened the devastating attack
that happened in Westminster
this was a man though this is who is a
52 year old from Kent yeah I agree with
you this is worse this is even worse the
fact that people are being radicalized
inside our prisons and we appear over
the last few years to have done nothing
about it so we've got two problems but
given we already have a problem okay
with people being radicalized at home
why on earth would you want to add to it
with an irresponsible immigration laws
you see valley is a different point
though isn't it you're talking you you
you again you are conflating I think
research is a made a slight mistake
I was very specific when I talked about
when I talked about jihadi ISM across
the whole of Europe and I repeat the
point as we have a homemade problem
already let's never add to it so you
admit then that immigration had nothing
to do with this terror attack not
directly no but that's not the point is
it the point is there are lots of terror
attacks taking place all across Europe
and many of them are people who
literally just arrived now that's a
bigger problem for France and Belgium
than it is for us because we're not part
of the Schengen zone and goodness we're
leaving the European Union even better
but we still have to be on our guard
so will you apologize then for appearing
there is a link between uncontrolled
immigration and what happened in
Westminster no absolutely no of course
not so what are you exactly saying then
if we if we're talking again about
people who are effectively homegrown
terrorists the people who are
a bracelet British you're talking about
in issues with the Muslim community what
you want to actually see happen now what
are two things really firstly people
should not be radicalized inside
state-run institutions and state-funded
institutions namely schools and prisons
and beyond that well clearly there is a
clearly I mean the biggest divide is the
divide within the Muslim community you
know the vast vast majority of Muslim
people in Britain want to be integrated
want to be part of our culture want
their kids to play in the street with
other kids and yet you know there is
this very dangerous minority who have
got a very dangerous interpretation of
what the latter parts of the Koran mean
and I would like to see actually the
Muslim community very openly having a
discussion about Islam or what it means
in the 21st century but it's already
happening isn't it we have our Singh
Muslim leaders coming out using a lot of
leaders um and condemning it as well is
that this is someone who is a convert to
Islam he's not someone who's brought up
as Muslim which again is a really common
factor within many people who go to
extremist beliefs yeah listen you know
the other way people can be radicalized
of course is through the internet that's
India and that's an even more difficult
job I accept for the government to deal
with I just think that the Muslim
community need to have an open honest
debate about what's going on for leaders
to stand up and say that what this man
did actually he wasn't really a Muslim
at all
that doesn't wash then he's been more
honest open debate about speaking about
honest debate that's why it's important
isn't it not to conflate immigration
with what happened in Westminster know
look you know open door immigration
across the Mediterranean has led
directly to terrorist atrocities in
Europe and goodness knows it not written
there hasn't been hundreds of British
people hundreds of us born people
committing terrorist well hundreds of
British people have been to fight in
Syria and many of them come back I'd
rather we didn't accept them back okay
and now when I last show where you came
on you talked talked about President
Trump and you said that his that
historically poor poll ratings were a
great place to start because it could
only go up from there now in that time
his poll ratings have slipped
failed to get through his flagship
healthcare reforms even to convince his
own party and he was also been
investigated by the FBI for allegedly
colluding with Russia no I mean he has a
problem of course he does that the
entire Washington establishment does not
want radical change of any kind at all
and trumpet his administration wanna
shake things up want to slim things down
and yeah he's got a big battle against
the Washington establishment I'm very
struck that with him failing at this
stage to get the health reforms through
Congress all that actually does is
strengthen his support with his key
voters in the country because that
message hey I'm on your side against the
establishment rings true